I've given myself a whole bunch of room, so
that I can write out all the steps that
I'm going to need to simply this
expression up here. So as we talked about
before, in other problems where we're
multiplying polynomials, to deal with
these 2, I'm going to start the 1st
term of the 1st polynomial and make sure
that I multiply it by every single term in
the 2nd polynomial. So I'm going to
write out all of those terms to start out.
So I have 3 terms here, reflecting the
fact that I multiplied this term by each
of the 3 terms in this expression. Now
that the -4x^2 is taken care of, I'll move
on to the x, since that's the next term in
this 1st polynomial. Once again, I
should add on 3 more terms to what I'm
building up here, 1 for each of these
terms, since I'm multiplying this by all
of them. So now I have 6 terms total,
which I can double check by counting them
all out. And this is actually a really
good way to check that you're on the right
track, in terms of the spot in the problem
you're at. If I've already multiplied out
the terms that I need for the first 2
terms of the 4 that I'm going to need
to multiply. And there are 3 terms
that I'm multiplying each of them by,
that'd make sense that I would have 2
times 3, or 6 terms total. Now let's
continue, by multiplying all of these by
2y. And finally, we get to the last
term in our 1st polynomial, the -6,
and now we have a super long expression.
This looks pretty miserable right now, but
hopefully, as we continue to simplify
within the terms, then combine like terms,
things will get to look a little bit
nicer. Really though, in terms of new
material that this problem covered, our job is
done. All that's left is for us to
simplify. Although, of course, this is a
particularly complicated simplification
process, because there are so many terms.
We just have to be super careful. We end
up with this lovely, very long final
answer of
-12x^2y^2+20x^3+3xy^2+6y^3-17x^2-10xy-18y^2+33x+6y-18.
Wow. That was really difficult, and if you
got this perfectly right, I am so proud
of you. I actually made a couple of
mistakes myself when I was redoing the
problem on the tablet here. You can see
actually, when I was doing my work, that I
had to put little check marks above all
the terms in this step before I got to the
final answer. The reason that I did that,
is that I wanted to make sure that as I
rewrote each term down here, and combined
it with it's like terms, that I prevented
myself from dealing with it again. So, I
put a little check mark above a term, when
I wrote it down here, that also let me
check that I actually had dealt with every
single term that I needed to deal with. I
think at this point, if you got this
problem right, you have mastered
multiplication of polynomials.
Congratulations. That's pretty huge.